actually we're here this morning for
screening of the diary of the wimpy kid
part 3 dog days what were you like as a
kid do think was I like as a kid quite
boisterous times and very clumsy to be
honest but definitely not a wimp so you
enjoy watching this series with your
kids yeah I mean they're big fans of the
I spoke to Mike one of my son's the
other day I asked him if you knew who
writes the books and he told me
straightaway so they're very very
probably not very very popular most kids
definitely and how do you think you are
the parent now still you know after I'm
trying to be a really really good parent
but there's still parts of me that is
very childish and basketballs they like
that they enjoy that about me son and
what's coming up next for you Ashley
well tomorrow I start filming tomorrow
for top way too so I'm pretty much out
in the game for the next three to four
months and that will be out on the
screens I think possibly before the in
the next year but in june next year I've
got my episode of Doctor Who that I did
recently so that should be good fun tell
me first a little bit more about top boy
tell me a little bit about what we can
expect from the next series and I think
you know more of the same we all know
what what style of show it is a very
kind of abrupt sort of expose about the
streets and the roads at the moment and
but you know from from last series we
ended with there being a few murders
been committed so from this series
starts with the investigation of those
murders is pretty much as much as I can
say and of course that you say you've
got doctor who and how exciting was it
to be involved in that yes it was
amazing and I was like a doctor who's
not about money or anything for me it's
just pretty much about being a part of
that huge franchise has been going on
for so long and working with matt smith
is amazing as well but also with that
I've been sworn to secrecy I can't say
anything about it because especially
with that show because the fans are so
into it and any inkling they get of a
storyline you know they run away with it
on the internet so yeah
it's an amazing episode of OJT and we
use fan of that when you're a kid as
well I used to watch it as a kid growing
up I mean once the new series started
and you know with David Tennant and with
matt smith and i haven't really watched
it that much but my uncle's are really
kinda phonetics they're in their forties
but they watch it religiously and
they'll be sitting there on Christmas
Day waiting for and everything as well
but yeah so it was just just good to be
involved and I think I've become more of
a fan by doing it he was your favorite
woman you're a kid who's your favorite
doctor I don't actually remember the
names of the others you know so I'd say
I mean like me and Matt was amazing and
this guy's he's so intelligent and
intuitive as an actor but also as well
he knows everything about Doctor Who so
I got most of my information from him
like it already tapped their four-year
yeah I didn't need to go out and do any
sort research I just kind of typed in on
Matt's oh yes a good and any films or
anything coming it for you as well I'm
kind of I'm producing at the moment I
just directed a pilot for a TV series
called The Charlatans so that's kind of
i'm in the edit suite kind of finishing
that at the moment and I producing the
film next year called break which is
about snooker about young kid using
Snuka to get the out of their ghetto I
suppose and also we're working me and no
Clark and it just elbow are working on a
film called full clip which is you know
similar thing to bad boys with mighty
lots of Will Smith in the US is about
like two cops two undercover cops in
London so we're working on it in a
moment we don't know what we're going to
go down a TV route and a filming with it
but what kind of role do you have in
that anything and with me and no will be
playing the lead so we're two undercover
cops that kind of get paired together
once a really good [ __ ] once a really
bad [ __ ] and it's just a dynamic between
them so it's kind of like a buddy movie
comedy but action as well sure you can't
wait to see that loads of stuff coming
it will loads of look with that and
can't wait to the Doctor Who as well
thanks very much Ashley
you